I played all the games already said it's
nice January which means there won't be
any more good games and filled I'm
nearly dead you play like hearthstone in
a bit of destiny
no I played Assassin's Creed the other
assess a dome order that's what it's
told air control it's always good I
played everything and less there's
exactly 10 games from 2014 2 haven't
played Thank You keep me entertained
until no man's sky arrives 11 games you
missed 11 games
it's hearthstone 1 no super time force
is one such game it's a side-scrolling
running gun where you can play as a
velociraptor on a skateboard that
travels to the future to get better
access to funny cat videos that's the
whole game it's like 2 percent of the
game it's rose up a middle finger to
conventional time-travel rules and the
butterfly effect teachers so dream in
favor of selfish japes that would have
Doc Brown all II also it's a decent
shooter you're not an unfeeling husk are
you know I love feelings well if 2014's
games left you feeling very little then
playing violent hearts the Great War
will pepper you with more emotions than
a World War 1 point with trench foot 2
which is also what valiant hearts is
about but not the fit the heartwarming
highs of heroics and reunion are met
with heartbreaking lowers of loss and
tragedy while teaching you about the
Great War through puzzles adventure and
discovery and there's a dog grip the
controller type it'll get slippery with
all those tears a much happier puzzle
adventure can be found in the Tallis
principal looks like mist it does look
like mist and it's kind of similar with
a dab of portal thrown in to explore the
gorgeous landscape solve the puzzles
play with the lasers love lasers I know
plus it'll make you do some real
thinking not just about the puzzles but
a deeper philosophical kind of thing so
that you may achieve eternal life sounds
heavy a much easier Zen can be found by
stabbing fools and nidhogg it's
positively jaunty grab a good friend me
I guess and go ahead to head with your
fellow sword stickman murderer and try
to outwit and at run them through a
series of rolls swipes jabs and jumps
and then eternal life ollie into
you win and then you get eaten by giant
worm then it's death and never seen your
sword loving family ever again
have you ever played Fez yes Ecco chrome
yes
journey in love journey then you
probably won't hate Monument Valley I
don't know it's a mobile puzzle game
that uses perspective and little moving
platforms in clever ways to test your
spatial thinking plus you have adorable
little princess Eider with her durable
little princess hat and where could she
be going to see friends who knows but my
god it's pretty powerful ascension will
also bring you many hours of great joy
plus it's for players that's practically
years of joy frantically you can take on
different characters you all happen to
be reasonable archers and then it's a
fight to the death in a platformer
dureena what's not to love well if all
that joy becomes overwhelming and you
need to quench a few rainbows you could
always play this war of mine gone is the
perspective of the soldier replaced with
that of the civilian and their struggle
to survive in a war-torn world sounds
great if you can handle the bleak
desperation and make the right choices
to cling to life then it absolutely is
but it's not a game that will have you
wading through a barrel of laughs which
is why you should play picks the cat
immediately after because it's like
wading through a shipping container of
ducklings and confetti just like my
birthday Yuka like eggs turn them into
tiny ducks and lead them to victory pads
like some kind of fluorescent Pied Piper
drop down another level collect more
ducks don't run into yourself and you'll
have a great day well if you're in a
halfway decent PC then you have to at
least experience walking around the
vanishing of Ethan Carter my god it's
stunning why yes it is but it's much
more than a tech demo you play a
detective investigating murders that
have happened around Red Creek Valley
what with all the astronauts astronauts
and notorious homicide fans never trust
them never have but if you have a Vita
and you're sick of being told to play
olly olly then you should get txk and
brace yourself for a broad spectrum
assault on the eyeballs
I got salt on my eyeballs once I'm sorry
to hear that exk is an insane cheap
shooter based on tempest that classic
arcade the very same but now you can get
power-ups plus the Vita is way more
portable than their 1981 equivalents
bonus game you should play threes Oh
like 20 40 years shut up about that game
threes is king this mathematical tile
based game will tax your mind and make
you dream in numbers you will miss bus
stops and lose loved ones in your
pursuit of a higher score wonderful and
is that yet more confetti it is what a
great game jisub you're absolutely right
there are loads of great games in 2014
that I should totally have played yeah
thanks for explaining half of them how
do they even do that your hostel
I like the exploding sheep
you